EU home affairs ministers have taken a
step towards improving border security
with their decision to bring the
powerful Schengen database syst 2 into
operation on april nine the system
allows border authorities and police to
share information on people and lost or
stolen property and goods it will be
able to use biometrics and have high
performance alerts while better
protecting personal data it will involve
a central database national systems and
a communication network to link them The
ministers also discussed the state of
play concerning Bulgaria and Romania is
entry into the Schengen passport-free
area now the council decided that the
issue will be again addressed before the
end of 2013 I don't expect it to be
addressed in any final form during the
course of the Irish presidency obviously
we will continue to do what we can to be
of assistance in resolving issues
the European Commission
failed it's smart borders package which
will speed the entry of business
travelers researchers and students who
live outside Europe the system will
record the data of all foreign nationals
when they enter and leave the minister's
asked council staff to begin work on the
proposals
in the wake of the conflict in Mali in
the hostage crisis in Algeria the EU
counterterrorism coordinator brief
ministers on the extent of the security
threat in northern Africa they
task-relevant EU actors to take forward
his proposals and requested an update in
October
justice ministers meanwhile moved
forward with work on a general framework
to protect data ensuring that this
security safety net keeps up with
developments in technology and
globalization they also looked at ways
to better prevent counterfeiting of the
euro and other currencies and approved a
compromise agreement with the European
Parliament on the recognition of
protection orders for the victims of
domestic violence